creepy kooky mysterious spooky Netflix's
Wednesday is all these things and more
and is mostly very successful at mixing
genuine scares with morbid humor but
every once in a while it doesn't quite
nail it these are the hit series biggest
hits and misses Wednesday Adams is
undoubtedly one of the most beloved
characters of The Addams Family
franchise her deadpan expressions and
Love of All Things Macabre are oddly
endearing traits that have made her an
American icon after the character was
portrayed by Christina Ricci in the 1991
and 1993 Barry sun and Feld movies
whoever would take on the mantle of
Wednesday would have some massive shoes
to fill thankfully Jenna Ortega is the
perfect choice for the gothic Cinderella
Ortega captures the spirit and look of
Wednesday atoms perfectly from her black
and white outfits to her Grim expression
and spot on sardonic delivery large
please remind my parents that I'm no
longer speaking to them
she delivers plenty of memorable moments
including taking revenge on the swim
team for bullying her brother Pugsley by
dropping a school of bloodthirsty
piranhas into the swimming pool and
another hilarious scene Wednesday is
forced to volunteer at the local Pilgrim
theme park for the school's outreach
program dressed in colonial Garb she
informs a group of tourists that the
fudge they are sampling is made from
cacao beans procured by the oppressed
indigenous people of the Amazon she adds
all proceeds go to uphold this pathetic
whitewashing of American History while
we'll always have a place in our hearts
for Richies Wednesday Ortega's portrayal
lives up to the legend the biggest
mystery in Wednesday involves a creature
called a hide which terrorizes the small
town of Jericho and the Nevermore School
Wednesday discovers that the hide is
actually a human who transforms into the
Ferocious Beast and that their abilities
were unlocked by someone who is now
controlling them Wednesday is determined
to find out the monster's true identity
as well as the person pulling the
strings Wednesday deduces that the
person helping the hide is Laurel Gates
the younger sister of Garrick Gates who
suffered a fatal accident at the time
Wednesday's parents attended Nevermore
Laurel is hiding her true identity
however Laura was praising drought but
no body was ever recovered at one point
Wednesday is visiting her friend Eugene
in the hospital when her court ordered
therapist Dr Valerie kinbot arrives with
a Vasa flowers after Wednesday leaves
kinbot neatly arranges the vase filled
with pale pink roses on a table the
camera focuses for a long moment on the
flowers so clearly they are important
sure enough when Wednesday Enid and
Tyler stake out the old Gates house they
find Laurel's old room recently lived in
and decorated with the pink roses from
the hospital this leads Wednesday to
believe that kinbot is actually the
missing Laurel Gates but it all fits a
little too neatly and the fact that the
hospital scene seems to linger a little
too long on the Roses makes it all too
clear that this is a classic and perhaps
too obvious misdirection
director Tim Burton has always had a
unique view of the world throughout his
most notable features such as Edward
Scissorhands Beetlejuice Frankenweenie
and 1989's Batman Burton's art reflects
his tendency to see the world from a
gleefully morbid perspective
[Music]
it's a wonder that it took so long for
him to deliver his own Take On The Adams
Family franchise because it seems to fit
him like a pair of lacy Victorian gloves
Burton directs four of the Eight
Episodes of Wednesday and is trademark
Gothic aesthetic is present throughout
Wednesday's monochromatic attire is
highlighted by various hints of colors
such as the stained glass window in her
dorm room that she shares with her
werewolf roommate Enid Enid's bright
personality is reflected in her fashion
and the window on her side of the room
is painted in bright colors Wednesday's
side meanwhile is colorless and Bleak as
is her half of the large window
Wednesday is even fitted with her own
custom black Nevermore Academy uniform
as she is apparently allergic to color
it isn't just Wednesday Adam's love look
that gets the Tim Burton treatment
Nevermore Academy itself with its Gothic
architecture and shadowy recesses are
also reminiscent of Burton's previous
work the design of the Hide monster is
also distinctly burtonesque with its
wide bulging eyes and rows of razor
sharp teeth
in her psychic Visions Wednesday is able
to communicate with the spirit of her
ancestor goody Adams Wednesday and goody
look almost identical and goodie is also
played by Ortega we learned that goodie
was a powerful witch who like Wednesday
had Visions she was a sworn enemy of
Jericho's oppressive founder Joseph
crackstone whose hatred of outcasts was
all-consuming in a truly despicable act
crackstone gathered all Jericho's
outcasts locked them in a barn and had
it set on fire leaving everyone inside
to burn alive goodie would later curse
crack Stones remain so that he could
never rise again many viewers might just
dismiss the name goodie as an
old-fashioned sign of the times but
anyone who is knowledgeable about early
American history or of Arthur Miller's
played The Crucible might raise their
eyebrows at this one because goody isn't
a name at all it's a title thoughtco
confirms that in the 17th century goody
was a title for a married woman it was
short for a good wife and would be
equivalent to today's use of Misses
there is no mention of goody Adams being
married and though it is possible that
the this was the case the show's writers
don't clarify so we're left to assume
that goodie is actually intended to be
her first name Wednesday even says it's
her name her name is Goodie Adams
at the heart of season one of Netflix's
Wednesday is a supernatural murder
mystery involving a bloodthirsty monster
a dark prophecy and a classic cover-up
scheme it all makes Wednesday's time at
Nevermore very memorable it all begins
when a gargoyle statue nearly crushes
Wednesday and it's clearly no accident
the murder attempt is thwarted when
fellow student Xavier Thorpe pushes
Wednesday out of the way just in time it
turns out that a fellow student with
telekinetic abilities named Rowan
believes that Wednesday is the source of
a prophecy that foretells nevermore's
Doom when Rowan attempts to attack
Wednesday directly he is killed by a
terrifying monster who then disappears
into the Shadows like the teen detective
in the novel she is writing Wednesday
takes it upon herself to uncover the
Seedy machinations happening at
Nevermore Academy she discovers not only
the dark history of the town of Jericho
and the real origin of the hide but the
secret that her parents Gomez and
Morticia have been hiding for years
Wednesday throws viewers for a loop as
each episode reveals more of the bigger
picture and ends with a truly surprising
twist
it's sad to say that the Wednesday
series uses the hackneyed Trope in which
the competitive popular girl can't stand
the presence of the weird new girl and
makes it her mission to take her down
Bianca Barclay is the most popular girl
at Nevermore Academy as well as a siren
with the power to use her voice to exert
her influence over others Bianca is
arrogant and Territorial and Wednesday
takes issue with Bianca's bullying the
moment Bianca and Wednesday meet there
is an immediate animosity between them
when Wednesday volunteers to spar with
Bianca in fencing class their exchange
is dripping with contempt you must be
the psychopath they let in and you must
be the self-appointed queen bee
interesting thing about bees pull out
their stingers and they drop dead the
Rivalry between Wednesday and Bianca
covers all the cliches down to the two
girls eventually learning to sympathize
and become allies the problem isn't that
there's conflict between the characters
the way it happens is just a little
played out
the handy thing plays a big role in
Netflix's Wednesday as the title
character's sidekick and Confidant
although he's sent by her parents to
Snoop on her Wednesday recruits thing
for her own service thanks to his quick
fingers and small stature thing can get
in and out of most places unseen making
him the perfect spy thing absolutely
steals every scene he's in even though
he's just a hand performer Victor
dorobantu is able to convey the most
complex of emotions we can feel his
grudging anger at Wednesday as he
indifferently flips through the pages of
a magazine we can also discern his
casual smugness as he sits on the
railing of Wednesday's bed swinging his
fingers back and forth like legs as he
presents the dress he stole for her
thing also has a really strong character
even though he can't speak he clearly
cares about Wednesday and his loyalty is
unshakable even when he doesn't agree
with her actions in the episode where
Wednesday finds thing impaled and
bleeding to death we couldn't help but
feel a sense of panic Uncle Fester is
able to save thing using his
electromagnetic Powers but the build up
to that moment is one of the tensest of
the series because viewers have built
such an attached judgment to Thing Once
Wednesday and Bianca set aside their
differences at the dance the series
begins to show Bianca in a new light at
Nevermore Academy's parents weekend
Bianca's mother a siren named Gabrielle
shows up unexpectedly we learned that
Gabrielle is a member of a cult called
morning song which Bianca has recently
escaped from they argue over Bianca's
return to the fold with Gabrielle
threatening to reveal the secret about
how Bianca made it into Nevermore Bianca
later promises her mother to return to
morning song at the end of the semester
but makes an interesting Claim about the
return but after this
you and morning song are out of my life
forever
it's fair to assume that the show will
attempt to delve deeper into Bianca's
character and morning song in its second
season but in the context of the first
season it's pretty disappointing the
show wraps up the subplot fairly quickly
which makes it feel like little more
than time filler of course we can't
predict what the plot for Wednesday
season 2 might be if it gets picked up
so it is possible that morning's song
might be a new source of conflict for
Wednesday and her friends in the future
the first name of the Adam family's
father being Gomez seems to imply that
his side of the family is of Hispanic
descent the Barry sonafeld films of the
90s ran with this concept casting Puerto
Rican actor Raul Julia as the patriarch
this idea continued with the release of
the 2019 animated film with
guatemalan-born actor Oscar Isaac
providing Gomez's voice Netflix embraced
this idea even further casting Jenna
Ortega who is of Mexican and Puerto
Rican descent in the titular role as
well as Puerto Rican actor Louise Guzman
as Gomez Wednesday isn't the first to
add diversity to The Adams Family
franchise but it is the first to cast a
Latin actor to play the goth teen the
show acknowledges Wednesday's Heritage
in various other ways in her dorm room
Wednesday often listens to Spanish
language music on her victrola it's also
established that Gomez's family
including his ancestor goody came from
Mexico in another episode Wednesday
mentions that her family keeps up their
ofrenda all year long for Dia de los
Muertos the Mexican Day of the Dead
For Better or For Worse there are
certain parallels between the outcasts
of Netflix's Wednesday and the lgbtq
plus Community being different is a
challenge for anyone but it can be even
more difficult when people have false
preconceived notions about who you are
for the students and faculty of
Nevermore Prejudice is an ongoing
concern from the local citizens of
Jericho a local group of Normie boys
frequently Delights in causing trouble
for the outcast kids they terrorize the
awkward Eugene during the town's
Outreach day as well as pull an
elaborate prank to ruin the school's
Raven dance even Jericho's mayor despite
outwardly claiming to want a peaceful
coexistence with Nevermore has his own
misgivings given the similarities
between the outcasts in Wednesday and
the real-life struggles of lgbtq plus
people it's a shame that the series is
sadly lacking in queer representation we
do learn that Eugene ottinger the
founding member of the beekeeping Club
at Nevermore has two mothers Janet and
Sue ottinger visit Eugene when he is
injured in the hospital this is the
extent of the show's lgbtq plus
inclusion however and it feels like it
was barely thrown in in the minimum
effort made is disappointing and we
certainly hope that in season 2 we'll
see a big Improvement